c'est que les montres ne tourne plus
forcément autant l'heure qu'à une époque
way s'est donné beaucoup un accessoire
et on alors un petit peu partout mais
reste toujours présente dans nos vies et
dans nos dents nous achat aussi dans
notre consommation
évidemment on se poser cette question
tout à l'heure pourquoi le logement en
franche comté
c'est une vieille histoire ça fait deux
cent cinquante ans que la franche comté
besançon le pays horloger le pays de
montbéliard le haut-jura tous ces
territoires là sont des territoires
d'horlogerie et finalement c'était
largement impulsée par la révolution
française qui a demandé à des horlogers
suisses sous sous le pilotage de
monsieur mégevand à l'époque de créer
une manufacture à besançon pour pour
l'état français de l'époque
c'est le début on va 93 florissante
au départ ça marche ça fonctionne claire
grand jour aujourd'hui mais différemment
alors évidemment il ya eu je prends
toujours comme référence en 1900 à
besançon qui était une ville d'à peu
près 40 mille habitants il y avait
treize mille salariés 13000 personnes
qui travaillaient dans l'horlogerie vous
rendez compte plus les familles c'est un
peu comme l'automobile à sochaux premier
employeur de la ville loin devant tout
le reste
oui vous ne disiez tout à l'heure pour
leap en l'occurrence c'est environ 120
personnes demain probablement plus
alors certains détracteurs diront oui
mais c'est dix fois moins qu'à l'époque
glorieuse dans la fin des années 70 mais
on est au 21ème siècle ça a évolué et
j'imagine que fabriqué aujourd'hui une
montre ça aussi évolué pierre albert ah
oui ça a beaucoup évolué et on est
effectivement aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
automatisée que hier donc on ne
retrouvera pas ses sur de tels niveaux
d'emploi pour une seule et même marque
après nous la volonté c'est vraiment de
de grandir et
l'horlogerie celle première employeurs
sur la franche-comté l'arc jurassien
qu'on soit du côté suisse ou du côté
français d'ailleurs et je pense que ça
le restera même si les emplois se sont
modifiés laurent vous le savez vous qu
est à la chambre de commerce pour les
côtoyer ces horlogers
là on a un exemple avec l entreprise
mégane a beaucoup d'autres évidemment on
est très fiers de la marque lippé alors
il ya d'autres marques à d'autres villes
et les montres péquignet par exemple
herbelin on peut citer lui je disais
alors zénith a une particularité aussi
des tout à l'heure c'était effectivement
une entreprise à besançon mais c'est
aujourd'hui de marque suisse et ça
illustre parfaitement l'écosystème
transfrontalier nous avons aussi on
estime à peu près à trois mille
personnes qui travaillent dans
l'horlogerie sur les territoires de
franche comté ain à peu en bourgogne ça
peut peut-être se dire un jour mais et
et il y en a beaucoup en suisse
d'ailleurs qu'en suisse on estime à peu
près 13 mille frontaliers qui tous les
jours travailler dans l'horlogerie
suisse
donc quand on ajoute tous ses effectifs
toutes ces personnes c'est près de 15000
personnes sur ces territoires qui
travaillent donc des français qui
travaillent soit en suisse ou en france
dans ce secteur sera là on vient de voir
quelques exemples de montrer si qu'on a
sur ce plateau avec différentes marques
justement est-ce qu'elles sont toutes
fabriquées comme on dit made in france
parce que souvent on a tendance à dire
est sûr très gentil mais finalement le
mécanisme
il n'est pas tout à fait français ils
les chinois et les japonais qu'est ce
que vous répondez
alors je réponds que malheureusement
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de mécanismes
100% français ça n'existe plus
nous nous avons fait le choix du swiss
made
puisque la suisse a conscience voilà
puisque la suisse a conservé une savoir
faire sur les mouvements au jour donc
l'horlogerie ça recoupe quatre grands
métiers vous avez les motoristes des
fabricants de mouvement vous avez les
carrures donc c'est le travail de
l'acier
vous avez le travail du verre et le
travail du cuir
sur france aujourd'hui sortie des
motoristes
on a encore tous ses savoir faire
assemblage montage réglages ccph
l'assemblage montage réglages ça s'est
fait en interne chez nous les bracelets
cuir par exemple pour prendre un exemple
très concret sont également faits à
besançon puisque les peausseries donc
viennent beaucoup de bourgogne puisqu'on
il ya des gros élevages de bovins et
tout ce qui est des coûts de couture des
bracelets cuir sont faits à besançon on
voit des exemples là à l'image
d'ateliers alors ce cas c'est qu'il ya
un panel de montre absolument surprenant
étonnant détonnant devrais même dire
parce que grosso modo ça va de la montre
bas de gamme jusqu'à la montre hors de
prix alors il y en a vraiment pour tout
le monde pour tous les goûts le mot bas
de gamme
oui c'est en tout cas entrée de gamme on
sait faire ça comme ça jusqu'au juste
que si on compare par rapport au haut de
gamme voilà voilà il n'y a pas de limite
vraiment s'appeler de 25 euros à
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
revoir deux millions d'euros
l'horlogerie c'est plus qu'une activité
économique aussi cessé du tourisme
autant de tout ça c'est une véritable
culture
on en est tous tant d'autres familles
d'aidé au relogement ma grand-mère et
horlogères voilà on a tout ça et donc
c'est ça profondément marqué la culture
de même que la suisse voisine on en
parle avec avec passion toujours
clairement oui c'était une affaire
d'actualité une histoire vivante
on peut les voir je me sens très
attentifs malgré tout vous n'avez pas
demandé si pour ça j'allais faire la
remarque en fait je cherchais de veilhan
et altera tu revenais pas de montre donc
là je vais peut-être tout mais qui paie
un prix il y a de quoi s'équiper 1 j'ai
vu quelques très beaux modèles
on va peut-être s'arrêter bien sûr sur
un modèle puisque depuis quelques
semaines l'ip est entrée à l'elysée
il est au rayon des goodies comme on dit
un des fameux cadeau dont on a tant
parlé ces derniers jours on regarde
cette montre et on est même allé faire
un petit reportage chez vous pour voir
ce que ça donne et on va en parler juste
après avec vous pierre alain bérard qui
est directeur général de chez lipp
regardez le sceau de l'elysée a posé sur
un cadran l'ip c'est un peu l'histoire
de la marque qui se perpétue le général
de gaulle a vécu son propre modèle
emmanuel macron a choisi lui d'en faire
un objet emblématique du made in france
comme une centaine d'autres produits qui
seront distribués par l'elysée parmi les
produits qui étaient présentes et il a
vu cette montre dauphine cette montre
libre dauphine qui est d'ailleurs
magnifique un cadran magnifique mais
surtout qui porte le bracelet bleu blanc
rouge quelques jours finalement après
que la france a été championne du monde
donc il a semble-t-il près ce qu'on me
dit vraiment beaucoup apprécié le
produit il l'a mis à son poignet il a
dit voilà la montrent que je vais porter
cet été vendu à l'occasion des journées
du patrimoine ou offertes par la suite
aux autres de marc reçu à l'elysée la
ligue dauphine version présidentielle a
déjà été fabriquées à une centaine
d'exemplaires
renouant ainsi une fois de plus avec
l'histoire du pays
c'est une partie quelque part de
l'histoire de france parce que les
montres lip était sur les poignées des
poilus en 14 était voilà c'est fait
c'est une belle marque
ces trois lettres je trouvais même ça
presque trop court et finalement l'ip
les gens s'en rappellent trois lettres
définitivement inscrite dans le
patrimoine horloger français pierre
alain bérard quand vous avez été choisi
par l'elysée
c'est entre le hasard
lachance donc monsieur macron
[Musique]
souhaité promouvoir le nom de l'elysée
et il ya également une volonté de
pouvoir restaurer donc le bâtiment de
l'elysée qui est quand même un bâtiment
qui a 300 ans et qui a besoin d'être
entretenue et donc il a eu l'idée que je
trouve plutôt très pertinente d'ailleurs
de faire un certain nombre de produits
aux noms de l'elysée et donc il a
missionné une société pour voilà
trouvait à l'appel d'offres voilà lança
un appel d'offres tout simplement
et ils sont tournés vers l'horlogerie et
donc je dirais la marque patrimoniale
horlogère française
et évidemment on a tout de suite dit oui
je suis allé faire un petit tour sur
votre site pour essayer de la commande
et oui pour pourvoir un petit peu bon
elle est aux alentours des 160 euros
c'est ça j'ai bien l'impression que on
peut pas la commande et on peut la
précommander ça veut dire que c'est un
succès oui pour l'instant c'est un
succès
au delà de nos espérances oui si on a
bien compris
au départ elle a été créée pour l'elysée
c'est ce que ce que vous ne disiez il ya
quand même eu un effet coupe du monde
derrière tout ça aussi parce que c'est
bien tombé vous avez entre guillemets de
la chance le bleu blanc rouge à la fin
de la coupe du monde
on rendait n'importe quoi là oui en fait
on a eu de la chance
donc on a eu l'idée de proposer ce
bracelet nato bleu blanc rouge et les
produits ont été présentés au président
de la république
peu de temps après la victoire de la
coupe du monde et en voyant le bracelet
aux couleurs de notre drapeau national
radio elle est belle celle là j'ai l'a
porté pendant les vacances ce qui fait
qu'on a eues il continue d'ailleurs de
la portée preuve que ça doit être plutôt
agréable à avoir au bras moi j'en suis
convaincu bon ok merci ça c'est pas de
la pub là c'est vraiment de lymphome et
puis en plus on est super fiers de
l'arrière de la région la laurence h et
toute la région qui rayonne à
l'international une fois de plus oui
évidemment dans ces très très belle
opération avec des pour jour territoire
de notable est très intéressant c'est
que c'est abordable pour quasiment tout
le monde parce que ça reste dans des
prix corrects on n'est pas sur des
choses hors de prix la wii wheel ippon
et en l'occurrence sur cet exemple là
cette voie là on est on est
effectivement très raisonnable en prix
et je trouve que c'est bien que d'autres
présidents porte une montre qui soit
accessible pour tout le monde
allez vous rester avec nous parce que on
parlera peut-être en haletant je pense
de l'horloge astronomique de besançon de
l'usiné d horlogerie dos d'âne du musée
du temps de l'école de l'horlogerie de
besançon il ya tellement de choses à
dire pourrait faire une émission tout
entière un sur sur l'horlogerie